nazi chat gruppe bei polizisten in
nordrhein-westfalen aufgeflogen nach
einer großrazzia wurden 29 beamte
suspendiert
ursula von der leyen verschärft die eu
klimaziele die europäische union sollen
noch schneller den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen senken und tausende
apotheken bangen um ausstehende
zahlungen der abrechnungsdienstleister
avp steht unter betrugsverdacht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wir
auch norbert lehmann für den sport ein
schillernder von mir
nordrhein westfalens innenminister
spricht von übelste und widerwärtigsten
hetze einer schande für die nrw-polizei
29 beamte die meisten aus essen sollen
rechtsextremes und rassistisches auf
ihren privaten handys geteilt haben
200 polizisten durchsuchten heute
dienststellen und privatwohnungen ihrer
kollegen und beschlagnahmten handys
torge bode hat details es war eine eilig
einberufene pressekonferenz des
nordrhein westfälischen innenministers
polizeibeamte die sich über jahre hinweg
gegenseitig bilder und texte mit
rechtsextremen inhalten geschickt hatten
schockierende nachrichten aus der
eigenen abteilung sie treffen diese
polizei bis ins mark
ich sag ihnen an meiner auffassung ist
dieser vorgang schande für die nrw
polizei
die ermittler hatten fünf chat gruppen
identifiziert alle mit teils
rechtsextremen inhalten 29 polizistinnen
und polizisten hätten daran teilgenommen
sie alle wurden vorläufig suspendiert 14
von ihnen droht eine dauerhafte
entfernung aus dem dienst mehr als 100
bilddateien wurden sichergestellt der
minister über deren inhalt entsetzt
bilder von hitler von hakenkreuzen von
reichskriegsflagge aber noch viel
abscheuliche bilder wie etwa der
fiktiven darstellung eines flüchtlings
in der gaskammer eines
konzentrationslagers oder einer
verächtlich machende darstellung der
erschießung von menschen mit schwach zu
haus frage deutschlandweit kommen immer
mehr fälle ans licht polizistinnen und
polizisten die unter anderem in chat
gruppen rechtsextremes gedankengut
verbreiten so etwa in hessen wo beamte
im zusammenhang mit dem verschicken von
droh-mails unterschrieben mit nsu 2.0
ins visier der ermittler rückten wir
können ja nicht überrascht sein wenn wir
schon in mecklenburg vorpommern und in
hessen und anderen ländern auch in
nordrhein westfalen schon fälle gesehen
haben wer da jetzt wirklich noch die
vokabel einzelfall in den mund nimmt dem
ist wirklich nicht mehr zu helfen
die ermittler gehen im aktuellen fall
davon aus noch weitere verdächtige zu
identifizieren
denn bislang konnte nur eines der
beschlagnahmten handys ausgewertet
werden
fälle von mutmaßlichem rechtsextremismus
bei der polizei online werfen wir einen
blick auf eine reihe von ähnlichen
vorkommnissen aus den vergangenen
monaten abrufbar in unserer zdf heute
app deutschland will rund 1500 weitere
flüchtlinge von den griechischen inseln
aufnehmen dieser koalitionskompromiss
hat unterschiedliches echo ausgelöst den
grünen ist es zu wenig die afg sieht
darin ein falsches signal heute
verteidigt der bundesinnenminister
seehofer im bundestag die entscheidung
sofort steht ein bundesinnenminister der
mehr als jeder andere auf der einen
seite die begrenzung und steuerung der
migranten entschieden hat und die bis
zur stunde der einzige minister europas
der für die humane antwort einen
lösungsvorschlag vorgelegt hat und ich
glaube darauf sollte deutschland stolz
sein eine europäische lösung das ist die
große hoffnung die eu-kommission will
kommende woche einen detaillierten
vorschlag dazu vorstellen
bislang steht deutschland ziemlich
allein da mit dem angebot mehr menschen
aus griechenland aufzunehmen
jürgen keller hat details auf den
griechischen inseln vor der türkischen
küste ist die lage prekär
rund 27.000 flüchtlinge die meisten aus
afghanistan und syrien leben hier unter
teils erbärmlichen bedingungen
deutschland will helfen in mehreren
schritten 408 familien davon etwa die
hälfte von lesbos dürfen kommen
insgesamt 15 153 menschen alle bereits
als schutzbedürftig anerkannt dazu 150
unbegleitete jugendliche aus dem
zerstörten lager moria und es läuft
bereits ein weiteres programm um
griechenland zu entlasten
hier geht es um 243 kranke kinder mit
ihren kern familien
insgesamt wird deutschland jetzt etwa
2800 geflüchtete aufnehmen sollte sich
die eu auf eine gemeinsame hilfsaktion
verständigen ist die bundesregierung
bereit die hilfe auszubauen
wer darf nun nach deutschland kommen die
griechische regierung wird es nur ganz
wenigen betroffenen aus dem abgebrannten
lager moorea zugestehen
sie fürchtet dass ansonsten flüchtlinge
auf den anderen inseln auch feuer legen
könnten um rauszukommen
trotzdem machen sich viele auf lesbos
hoffnungen andreas postel ist vor ort
sony hat neue hoffnung geschöpft dass
sie mit ihrem ehemann und den zwei
kleinen kindern zu den auserwählten
gehört die nach deutschland kommt ihren
schutzstatus ist geklärt
trotzdem waren auch sie noch im lager
moria als es brannte
seitdem campieren sie am straßenrand ich
hatte mal ein anhörungstermin kurz vor
ausbruch des feuers und nächste woche
soll ich die stempel bekommen mit denen
ich die insel verlassen kann
deshalb wollen sie jetzt in das neue
zeltlager charakter gehen welches
griechenland mit internationaler hilfe
auf lesbos errichtet hat es bietet platz
genug für alle schutzbedürftigen heißt
es gewalt und brandstiftung bringen
keine lösung wir benötigen ein
friedliches geordnetes verfahren mit dem
die menschen von lesbos weiterkommen und
das ist das was wir hier unterstützen
die griechischen behörden haben
unterdessen sechs mutmaßliche
brandstifter afghanischer herkunft
ermittelt nachdem videos aus der
brandnacht und handydaten mit
zeugenaussagen abgeglichen wurden
auch die internationale hilfe kommt
mittlerweile voran
das rote kreuz hat mehrere
transportflüge nach lesbos organisiert
ermöglicht durch zwei großspenden
deutscher unternehmen mit insgesamt drei
krater flügel bringen wir insgesamt 500
zelte her die unterkunft für ungefähr
2500 menschen liefern werden mit
flugblättern versuchen die behörden nun
die menschen davon zu überzeugen in das
neue camp zu gehen doch bei vielen ist
die befürchtung groß dass sie nicht
weiterkommen nach westeuropa sondern
nach wie vor auf lesbos festsitzt
für ursula von der leyen war es heute
eine premiere nach fast einem jahr als
kommissionspräsident in ihre erste rede
zur lage der europäischen union
dabei sprach sie die aktuellen
baustellen gleich reihenweise an allen
voran den klimawandel die bereits
gesteckten ziele der gemeinschaft will
sie noch mal nach oben schrauben dann
der kampf gegen korona da schwebt ihr
ein globaler gesundheitsgipfel vor und
in der flüchtlingskrise machte sie allen
mitgliedsländern einmal mehr druck in
aragon
es ist die erste rede der
kommissionspräsidentin zur lage der
europäischen union und sie fällt in eine
zeit in der korona so vieles verändert
hat perfekt soll die kulisse sein darum
wird mittendrin schnell noch die flagge
gerichtet sie ist im moment für europa
europa muss nun den weg weisen um die
unsicherheit in neue lebenskraft polizei
münzen to the new reality in der
gesundheitspolitik müsse die eu enger
zusammenarbeiten bei der digitalisierung
schneller vorangehen hoch hinaus wie sie
in der klimapolitik die treibhausgase
bis 2030 sollen im vergleich zu 1990 um
mindestens 55 prozent reduziert werden
statt bisher 40 prozent das wird von
einigen gefeiert und von anderen mit
vorsicht behandelt
wir fordern dass ambitionierten zielen
auch eine antwort darauf folgt wie viel
das alles kostet und wer dafür bezahlen
muss und wir brauchen dafür einen
breiten gesellschaftlichen konsens das
drama von moria hat druck gemacht
deshalb will die kommission nächste
woche nun endlich das migrations paket
vorlegen das setzt auf außengrenzen
schutz schnellere asylverfahren und auf
solidarität
migration ist eine herausforderung für
ganz europa deshalb muss auch ganz
europa seinen teil leisten sagt sie und
weiß genau das hat trotz vieler appelle
bis heute nicht funktioniert
ich fordere sie auf den kampf mit den
mitgliedstaaten aufzunehmen um es zur
obersten priorität zu machen menschen in
not zu helfen und ihnen diesen zustand
nicht hinzunehmen
höflich der applaus im europaparlament
denn vieles blieb und konkret und
umgesetzt werden können große visionen
nur wenn die mitgliedsstaaten auf mitte
30 jahre deutsche einheit am dritten
oktober wird es offiziell gefeiert heute
gab es den einheits bericht der
bundesregierung fazit ost und west sind
sich in vielem näher gekommen
aber es bestehen noch unterschiede vor
allem bei den löhnen durchschnittlich
verdient ein beschäftigter im westen
brutto 3340 im osten 2850 euro
umgekehrt ist es bei den renten im
westen betragen sie im schnitt 856 euro
im osten sind sie höhere 1050 euro buy
in der ddr mehr frauen gearbeitet haben
andreas weise über den stand bereit es
ist viel passiert dort wo vor 30 jahren
noch die ddr war aber noch nicht genug
so marco wanderwitz ost beauftragter der
bundesregierung der heute den bericht
zum stand der deutschen einheit
vorstellte
wir sehen gleichwohl auch wenn wir bei
dem thema gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse weit vorangekommen
sind natürlich immer noch messbare und
sichtbare und auch in dem empfinden der
leute vorhandenen disparitäten
beispielsweise einkommen sind
beschäftigungsmöglichkeit ausstattung
mit infrastrukturen angebote der
daseinsvorsorge
es gibt immer noch zu tun in ländlichen
gebieten ist der unterschied kaum noch
spürbar
doch das reicht nicht aus für
wirtschaftsforscher sind die städte die
wachstumslokomotiven die urbanen
ballungsgebieten hingegen unterscheiden
sich noch deutlich dort ist die
wirtschaftskraft erst bei ungefähr 75
prozent in ostdeutschland verglichen mit
westdeutschland wenn man also diesen
aufholprozess weiter befeuern möchte
dann muss man sich um die urbanen
ballungsgebieten kümmern
die neuen bundesländer leiden unter
überalterung und jahrzehntelange
abwanderung gut ausgebildeter
arbeitskräfte kein großkonzern hat
seinen sitz hier eine stärkere
rechtsextreme tendenzen schrecken
dringend benötigte fachkräfte oft ab
schlecht für innovationskraft und
wachstum
wir haben nur eine größere diversität
der gesellschaft in westdeutschland und
eben dort vor allem
den urbanen ballungsgebieten als das in
ostdeutschland der fall ist und daher
hängt natürlich auch mit so etwas wie
willkommenskultur oder der bereitschaft
für zuwanderung zusammen
blühende landschaften schon nach 30
jahren vielleicht ein etwas zu
ambitioniertes ziel
und jetzt zur corona lage da sind die
registrierten neuinfektionen leicht
angestiegen
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1440 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern waren es 1370 damit
die unternehmen in der korona krise ihre
mitarbeiter möglichst nicht entlassen
verlängert die bundesregierung das
kurzarbeitergeld das kabinett beschloss
dass beschäftigte die staatliche hilfe
24 monate statt bisher zwölf bekommen
können maximal bis ende des jahres db
cargo diese tochter der deutschen bahn
kümmert sich um den güterverkehr und
macht damit seit jahren schon miese eine
art rundum sorglos paket für die kunden
soll das jetzt ändern
der druck auf das unternehmen ist riesig
allein im vergangenen jahr kamen mehr
als 300 millionen euro verlust zusammen
gleichzeitig ist die lkw konkurrenz
billiger auch deshalb laufen seit jahren
nur rund 18 prozent des warenverkehrs
über die schiene hans jürgen papier
wie soll der güterverkehr der deutschen
bahn aus der verlustzone kommen mehr als
die hälfte aller frachtaufträge geht
bereits an die privatbahnen konkurrenz
sie soll das ändern sigrid nikutta
bisher chefin der berliner
verkehrsbetriebe leitet seit januar db
cargo will die güterbahn jetzt zum bahn
logistiker ausbauen
zukünftig werden wir die waren bei
unseren kunden abholen
auch mit anderen verkehrsmitteln wir
erwarten nicht dass sie zu uns gebracht
werden sondern wir holen sie wir machen
diese logistik zudem sollen schon bald
nachtzüge wirtschaftszentren im
pendeltakt verbinden und neue
verladeterminals errichtet werden für
den transport hierhin wenn man auch mit
zum unternehmen kooperieren
doch experten bezweifeln dass der umbau
in die richtige richtung geht
man hört eben im markt dass db cargo
einfach und zuverlässig ist
dass sie zu teuer produzieren dass sie
langsam sind auf kundenwünsche zu
reagieren und das sind also die
organisatorischen probleme
die ddb angehen müsste und davon hört
man im moment nichts an ideen private
güterbahnen klagen währenddessen
aktuellen über kampfpreise des
staatskonzerns dabei soll der milliarden
hilfen aus steuermitteln bekommen
wettbewerbspolitisch ist es aus unserer
sicht ein skandal dass der bund als
eigentümer mit steuergeldern die db
cargo dazu ermächtigt wettbewerber aus
dem markt zu preisen und damit
letztendlich den markt wieder ärmer zu
machen
denn brüssel hat der privatbahn verband
jetzt beschwerde eingelegt will
erreichen dass die zahlung der korona
hilfsgelder an die db mit auflagen
verknüpft wird für tausende apotheken
ist es ein gravierendes problem sie
warten gerade vergeblich auf die
erstattungen der krankenkassen für
medikamente die sie auf rezept
herausgeben doch das unternehmen das für
sie diesen zahlungsverkehr abwickelt
steckt in schwierigkeiten
nach schätzungen könnte es um hunderte
millionen euro gehen anton kuh schicken
berichtet betreibt eine apotheke im
rheinland-pfälzischen wörrstadt das
geschäft läuft gut auch die abrechnung
über den dienstleister avp funktionierte
jahrelang reibungslos doch plötzlich
bleibt das geld aus ich bekomme ungefähr
noch 100.000 euro von der afp
und da sie heute insolvenz angemeldet
haben rechne ich nicht mehr damit das
geld zu bekommen
unklar ist wo das geld geblieben ist und
ob es bei avp einen kriminellen
hintergrund gibt klar ist die
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht bafin
ermittelt in dem fall und hat
strafanzeige erstattet
außerdem hat sie insolvenzantrag für die
avp gestellt zunächst muss der
vorläufige insolvenzverwalter prüfen ob
ein eröffnungs und grund vorliegt und ob
die kosten des insolvenzverfahrens durch
das vermögen der gesellschaft gedeckt
wären
normalerweise kommen die apotheken so an
ihr geld sie reichen die rezepte für
medikamente monatlich bei av p1 vp
rechnet die rezepte mit den
krankenkassen ab und bekommt das geld
erstattet und leitet den betrag an die
apotheken weiter
seit wochen aber kommt kein geld mehr an
das bedeutet wir sind im bereich
zwischen 300 und 500 millionen euro die
jetzt letztendlich fehlen bei den
dreieinhalb tausend apotheken das ist
für eine monatsabrechnung ganz großer
batzen und das kann im schlimmsten fall
die pleite bedeuten stephanie koch ist
aber guter dinge durch ihre rücklagen
kann sie wohl weitermachen auch wenn sie
das geld nie mehr sehen sollte noch eine
kleine korrektur ich habe eben gesagt
dass das auf 24 monate verlängerte
kurzarbeitergeld bis maximal ende dieses
jahres gezahlt wird aber es wird
natürlich bis maximal ende kommenden
jahres gezahlt wird entschuldigen sie
dass im westen der usa toben verheerende
waldbrände im südosten des landes drohen
dagegen massive regenfälle durch
hurrikan sally mit windgeschwindigkeiten
von mehr als 160 stundenkilometern fegte
der hurrikan in alabama an land laut
us-behörden sind historische
überschwemmungen möglich sally ist einer
von derzeit 5 tropischen wirbelstürmen
im atlantik ein phänomen das erst einmal
registriert wurde vor 50 jahren jetzt
zur tour de france norbert da ging's
heute hoch her in den alten ja denn das
ziel dieser königsetappe
das liegt in 2300 vier metern höhe eine
kräfteraubende kletterpartie für die
radprofis sieg der kolumbianer miguel
angel lópez vor dem slowenen in gelb
republik der deutsche vortagessieger
lennart kemmler heute chancenlos
75 kilometer vor dem ziel am ersten
großen berg dem col de la madeleine muss
lennart kemna seinem triumphalen
kraftakt von gestern tribut zollen er
fällt aus der spitzengruppe zurück der
letzte anstieg auf das dach der tour bei
mary bell wird zu einem
ausscheidungsfahren der favoriten
der viertplatzierte kolumbianer miguel
angel lopez hat bei der bergankunft mit
bis zu 24 prozent steigung die besten
beine
er gewinnt vor dem slowenen primoz rock
ridge der seinen vorsprung im gelben
trikot weiter
15 sekunden nimmt er seinen schärfsten
konkurrenten landsmann roger ab mit 57
sekunden ist er jetzt vorne
morgen geht es in den alpen weiter ex
leichtathletik-welt präsident lamine
diack ist in paris wegen korruption
verurteilt worden die strafe vier jahre
haft von denen zwei auf bewährung
ausgesetzt wurden sowie eine geldbuße
von 500.000 euro der 7 der 87 jährige
senegalese soll in seiner amtszeit
mehrere millionen euro vor wien von
russischen athleten für die vertuschung
von positiven doping-test erpresst haben
jack hat berufung eingelegt und vor dem
münchner landgericht hat heute der
bisher größte doping prozess in
deutschland begonnen
im mittelpunkt steht der erfurter arzt
mag es der weltweit blut doping und
doping missbrauch vor allem im rat und
wintersport organisiert haben soll
alles beginnt mit der operation aderlass
im februar 2009 10 durchgeführt als
razzia schlag gegen doping bei der
nordischen ski-wm in seefeld mit dem
österreichischen langläufer max hauke
der bei einer unerlaubten
bluttransfusion auf frischer tat ertappt
wird und dem deutschen sportmediziner
marquez der fast zeitgleich in erfurt
festgenommen wird
er soll der drahtzieher eines
internationalen doping netzwerkes sein
und laut staatsanwaltschaft regelmäßige
doping praktiken in einer unbekannten
vielzahl von fällen durchgeführt haben
das verfahren ist insofern von
besonderer bedeutung als erstmalig im
profisport
das anti doping gesetz zur anwendung
kommt deshalb können die angeklagten zu
einer freiheitsstrafe von bis zu zehn
jahren verurteilt werden
26 verhandlungstage sind zunächst
angesetzt der letzte in diesem jahr für
den 21
dezember der heute leider recht viele
schattenseiten des sports
vielleicht hätten die lottozahlen so
manchen auf sie lauten 8 31 41 43 44 48
und die superzahl 8 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
das wetter wird kühler schauer und
gewitter gibt es aber nur im süden die
details hat gleich gunter czisch
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
wir bedanken uns für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
abend bis morgen wenn sie mir auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau wie liebe zuschauer morgen ist die
große hitze bei uns vorbei aber der
große regen ist auch nicht in sicht die
luft kommt aus norden derzeit sie ist
trocken und sie ist kühl deshalb gibt es
morgen in norddeutschland keine 20 grad
mehr im süden sind noch angenehmer und
die große hitze liegt weiterhin über
frankreich auch in den nächsten tagen
mit spitzenwerten bis zu 35 grad und bei
uns wird es in der kommenden nacht schon
richtig frische morden da sind es wieder
nur sieben bis acht grad ansonsten im
süden deutlich milder schauer und einige
gewitter hier über süddeutschland
sie werden langsam schwächer aber im
osten eher noch stärker wenn die ganze
nacht dort zu dicht der donau ziehen
vielleicht auch mal richtung erzgebirge
und dazu wird dieser frische kräftige
nordost in denen haben auch tagsüber
dazu strahlender sonnenschein in
norddeutschland wolkenloser himmel erst
für den mittelgebirgen wird es dann
wolkiger und südlich des mains ist es
auch mal stark bewölkt vor allen dingen
hier in bayern es gibt immer wieder
schauer und gewitter die sich tagsüber
dann zu den alpen zurückziehen die
temperaturen eher ein temperatursturz
über norddeutschland 16 bis 20 grad nach
28 grad heute und im süden haben wir
nochmal 25 oder 27 grad am rhein
die aussichten trockenes wetter auch
wieder über das wochenende mal ist es
sonnig mal wolkig und meist so 19 ist 27
grad
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut